Nhan sống các giám nhân sử li bang đang trở thành điều dệnh gió nhất của cuộc khủng hoảng lần xác kéo sài tại Mỹ.
Vì bộ tư pháp Mỹ cho hơn 1 nghìn 1 trong người bị thuộc việc không chỉ gây đình trẻ hoạt động của nhiều các quan trí phụ.
Mặc còn tạo ra hiệu ứng tâm li bắt hồn trong lực lượng ở động cơm.
Như cơ quan như chúng ta mì kìm xóa và phòng ngờ dịch bản xây đi xe.
2 bộ sâu dụng phải tu hẻ hoạt động.
Anh hưởng trực tiếp đến dịch 1 công thiết yêu.
Dạ báo về các giám dự kiến sẽ còn tiếp tục dính xa.
khi mà thương viện này mới muốn đông người đámu lần nữa,
bác bỏ sử lột tay trở tạm thời sâu đàn công hòa hổ thống.
Qua đỏ kéo sách tình trạng không hoạt động của chính phủ li bang sang tổn thứ ba.
Với về thương viện tiếp tục bác bỏ sử lột thương tay trở tạm thời này.
Không hoảng sách được dự báo sẽ còn kéo sài.
Đây này này này này này này mình nghĩ vào dự đoạn tới liện nghiêm trọng hơn.